escape from la with a last-gasp win  sunday the las vegas raiders snuck out  of southern california with a big win  over the  chargers yesterday's game came down to  just a matter of  centimeters look at this here fourth  quarter seconds left raiders  up 31-26 when there you see la's justin  herbert tossed what appeared to be the  game-winning touchdown as time expired  there's a long review the play was  overturned and  las vegas won you can only imagine it's  it's what you you're in this business  for  it's why fans love it it's it's really  what makes the world go around you know  the the competition  and the excitement uh the thrill of  victory and the agony of defeat  next up the raiders are going to take on  another afc west team it's the denver  broncos they come to town on sunday a  game you can see right here on channel  8.